from NBC sports and one of the voices of
the NHL on NBC and NBCSN and the family
of network said I'll check how are you
Eddie hi rich I'm doing well hope you're
doing well it's the same during this
these crazy times so health and health
and happiness to you in yours well I was
gonna ask you that question because I
know you are somebody who would be at
risk and what's going on with you now
feeling good yeah it's hard to believe
I'm 2 years since my my battle with
stage 3 colon cancer and officially got
my I got my yearly scan the other day
and it came back all clean and clear
long very lucky very blessed and just
count just trying to do the the right
things
you know by you know by my you know for
myself and my family and abiding by the
medical professionals and but I'm
feeling good and some great news
yesterday probably the best medicine
that I've had in a long time here in the
commissioner jump on there and give the
format and the return to play and I
think the one thing too rich I think the
league led by the Commissioner mr.
Batman and the Deputy Commissioner Bill
Daley I think the league has done an
unbelievable job here since the pause
like since the middle of March they've
been out there they've been answering
questions they've given information when
it was there and you know they've gone
you know underground when there was
really nothing to say and then to be
able to get together with the board of
governors and owners and then obviously
the players and the return to play
committee to be able to come together
and say okay look if we can if we can
accomplish this this is the way it's
going to be and look at you you can poke
holes at it you can you know break it
down and you know some teams you know
Buffalo and New Jersey for example on
the outside looking in there had a
couple of games in hand and you know you
could argue it until you're blue in the
face but look and I think that they
deserve a lot I think the leadership the
Commissioner showed was second to none
during this whole thing look we're we're
probably 10 minutes into the first
period through this whole process right
now and hopefully we'll get back to
playing but at least everybody has an
idea and let's get through the first
couple of phases and then we'll worry
about dropping the puck when the time
permits and again that will all be
because of the safety in the aspect and
the the guidance of the medical
professional so
I guess then let's get into the format
here right let's talk a little sport
let's do it does this format do you
think benefit one team over another just
based on it first flush looking at it
well I mean I think when you when you
break it down you know you mentioned
rich you know the top four teams in each
conference getting a Buy and then
they'll you know they'll play a little
round robin to play the seating there
you know the interesting thing is is
that you had teams that were on the
outside looking in right when the pause
happened the teams that were sitting at
nine ten eleven twelve all of a sudden
they may be eight nine points out of a
playoff spot and here they are getting
an opportunity to challenge for you know
in my opinion the greatest trophy in all
professional sports so when you look at
from that aspect of it it's an
opportunity for four teams that you know
maybe thought that hey you know they had
to go on an unbelievable run before the
pause and and have a chance at you
getting into the playoffs so you know
that that that to me is when you look at
the the five versus 12 is going to be I
mean it's it's wide open rich I don't
think anything that anybody did prior to
the PAS
prior to the pause really has no you
know no relevance in in what's going to
take place here because this is
absolutely unchartered territories I
mean these guys most of these guys will
have been off the ice almost like an
offseason you know like an off season
and you know if we've had any normalcy
in our life they'd be off the ice for
maybe three plus months and then you
know now they're gonna go and they're
probably going to have their informal
skates you know they can skate with
their teammates up to six at their
facilities when that opportunity
presents itself in the next phase and
eventually no earlier than the middle of
July that they will have the formal team
practicing but I don't think if I really
I really don't I don't think it favors
anybody I think you could sit there and
say you know what if you like the
longest shot on the board and being a
horse player rich as you know I am if
you got that courage and gumption to
think wow this team's got a goaltender
this guy's got a star player why can't
they why can't they go on a run because
that's what you got to do so for me a
lot of scenarios out there the
possibilities of how we were going to
get this thing done and I think that the
league and along with the players again
don't
don't forget the players had a big say
in this they came to the best conclusion
and looking forward to see how this
format plays out especially once you get
past you know the first preliminary
rounds rich because you got this five
versus 12 just like the NCAA right you
know the March Madness is is once you
get through that are they going to have
a bracket situation or are they going to
reseed and then go from you know the
highest ranked team to the lowest and
then have them play that's all they'd be
determined as you mentioned a little bit
earlier so that's the exciting part is
how they're going to decide how this
thing all plays out well I know I might
sound like a Southern California any old
chick but you know I'm also got a New
Yorker in me too wouldn't it be
interesting that if the Canadiens
finally break the McSorely stick curse
under this format they go from my 12
season going on a run they got the
goalie that could do it rich they got
the goalie that can do it very price
there's there's no doubt they've got
some holes there and I don't think the
holes have been plugged up since the
pause montreal montreal is gonna have a
tough time here you know as they move
forward in these and against that first
series against pittsburgh yeah I was
thinking to you know when are gonna I
know this is the seedings are based on
Division standings not just points man
and again the New Yorker me I would have
loved to see Rangers Islanders right
that they they play each other right
then and there maybe they could play it
right there in Rockefeller Center in the
rink you know do the full-on synergy
with NBC and just play it out playing
outdoors I don't know if it's a see I
don't think it's a regulation-size rink
that's right there and in Rockefeller
well isn't it again isn't that the rules
right that regular season overtime rules
apply early on you know forth for
therefore for the Ron rod for the for
the top four seeds English but the other
the other five the other series are
going in so to speak those are those are
over time you schedule 3 for overtime
yes that's it and then again Eddie I
mean I'm assuming with the player is
already coming off a quarantine the
playoff beards would be particularly
great I mean like in terms of all-time
playoff because I've been told is that
hair grows more in the summertime so I'm
assuming that Wow I know and all the
sharks are not in it but Brett Burns and
Jill Thornton couldn't have years down
to there
but yeah they could be like ZZ Top right
to go old-school right there you know
two minutes two minutes for low bearding
you know there could be something like
that
so I mean this this is genuinely
exciting that that's it do you do know
it what have you heard from players
about concerns about returning to the
sport and what might be going on back
and forth on that on that front yeah
talking to a lot of players throughout
the league and yeah there there there
obviously is that concern and you know
that's where you're you're you're
gathering your information from the
medical professionals and then how are
we going to have a safe healthy
environment and that's what the
Commissioner is said from day one and
you said that yesterday again and when
you addressed everybody of look at that
the safety and health of everybody
involved is at the forefront of this and
how do you have a competitive balance
there with you know with the contact
sport I mean that's just the reality of
it and you know how do we keep our
players safe and the officials as well
let's not forget the officials that are
going to be in the middle of so that's
why you know there's there's this great
optimism and look I mean we're all
living in a most difficult time and it's
hard to turn on the television and just
hear you know I don't want to say the
negativity but certainly just you know
bringing everybody down with what's
going on and it's hard not to be just
weather whether it's personally or
professionally or you know just what's
going on a society but when you have
this hope here about oh wow maybe you
know in our little world we're going to
get back to seeing hockey but to have
the format out there that is just
awesome
but then again the hurdles are from the
players aspect of it is okay so how are
we going to do this how are we going to
keep everybody safe what happens if
somebody does get sick how is that going
to be affected who's going to be doing
the testing how is that going to be
administered who's going to make the
final decision all of those things are
still you know obviously have been
talked about rich but you know those
things have to be you know worked out
you know a lot a lot of talk and I've
heard it with Major League Baseball and
and also at the NBA is you know how our
family is going to be implemented here
you know I mean you can you can only put
these guys or any situation you only put
them in a bubble you know and be
protected so much I mean there's
going to be outside you know there's
going to be outside structure there at
some point I mean whether you're going
in a hotel there are hotel workers I
mean that right that's one of the
questions as well if you're going into a
hotel or resort are all these hotel
workers going to be staying in these
hotels and not going home and then
coming back and working and cleaning
your room or feeding that you know
serving the food the bus drivers you
know all that kind of stuff so there's
so many things that you know that that
obviously still need to be worked on but
you know they that's why they're there
they have the committee and you know
this is like I said you're just 10
minutes in in the first period of this
of this this whole game here to
hopefully get us back sooner than later
and hopefully we're back at the end of
July or early August and then just to
wrap things up with you Eddie I'll check
I mean you don't talk about the boy you
you you you hit a I guess what would you
say an exact uh or where you you not
only heard from hockey here the the
folks at in New York City say that let's
run the Belmont on June 20th and so I
mean that you know you might have no I
just made a nice little exact of you by
I hope you boxed that okay so at any
rate what are you what's your first
blush thoughts on the race that's for
the first time the first leg of the
Triple Crown and obviously they
shortened the length of the race one
would you know cuz horses are just like
any other athlete that you've got a
condition um you can't just run them a
mile and a half right out of the out of
the gate so we're gonna think first
bless you and well I think it's being
proactive I think that you know New York
Racing Association and you know
obviously the Triple Crown looks at this
and go to face the first goal is simple
crown and you know we're we're gonna
sort in the race and do right by the
animal and do right by these you know
the sport in the game and we're gonna
run it a mile and an eighth and set a
mile and a half and and they're gonna
have a full field I believe of I think
16 horses and it's going to be
unbelievable and now that I think is the
right thing and I think what has
happened now rich is that what you're
going to see that is you're going to
have horses that are obviously maturing
into there
your old campaign and some horses just
aren't mature enough to be ready to run
in in their early three-year old
campaign so that's why it's so difficult
to get the horses to the Kentucky Derby
the first Saturday May where now it's
going to be the first Saturday in
September so I'm fine with it look at
its it's gonna hopefully it's hopefully
hopefully it's probably here in here
then we go to a mile and an eighth but
you know hey the whole mine gets a
chance to kick off the Triple Crown and
we'll see if somebody can pull off the
feat and if they happen to do it then up
to me I will not look at it any
differently than I would a normal triple
comm because look at this is the hand
that's been dealt you got to handle the
adversity and I think horse-racing to
this point is handled it extremely well
and I'm looking forward to being our NBC
horse racing teams coming we have the
best leadership and looking forward to
being a part of the the Belmont coverage
on NBC starting undoing the client catch
you man
your your your team player right there
even though there is an eye on Eddy but
not Olczyk hey man I'm glad to have you
here and I'm glad that we you know it
again we just don't know the where and
when obviously two crucial question
marks that need to be exclamation points
but it was still like you said great to
hear here's the format here the team's
just seeing the logos seeing team logos
just hearing hearing the names of the
teams it was great he's a lot of fun you
know you gotta you take care of yourself
that's a whole check of NBC Sports in
the NHL on NBC and also as you pointed
out Triple Crown racing on NBC hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here